Have you heard about VidMe? Let's talk about VidMe.
So, last week I wrote a tweet thread mocking VidMe, a new competitor to YouTube...
for their poor site design, hinging on the fact that they don't look serious.
Their site layout makes it look empty, and they are apparently so devoid of content that...
"Why I'm leaving VidMe" videos are rising to the top.
It's not a good look.
Now, the thread was seen by Alex Benzer, one of the co-founders of VidMe,
and Guy Gunaratne, one of the co-founders of Storygami, the platform that powers Maven Video.
Both of them were understandably a bit hurt by the roasting and implored me with a similar plea:
"Get involved, give feedback, shape the future".
And that is...
It's a nice sentiment, but...
no, I'm not going to do that.
Well, I sort of am, but not directly.
What I'm going to do instead is, later on, I'll rant at length about YouTube's failings.
and let you extrapolate from there
Online video hosting is expensive, really expensive
An online presence consists of two major cost factors: storage and bandwidth
and video hosting is kind of the worst of all worlds
With video, there's the added fact that your product, your content, consists of a lot of really large files
Not only do you require the kind of high bandwidth connection of any popular site
You also need a lot of storage to host all of that content
Because of this cost reality, it's simple to say that anyone attempting to build a competitor to Youtube is in some pretty deep money
Anyone who even tries with less will be bankrupt by the end of their first month
With that in mind,
You're not paying me to do product development,
but I know you can afford it
You're presumably already paying people to do research and development for you
And that likely includes people whose job is to search Twitter, Reddit and comment sections
looking for what people have to say about your product
Are they talking about it as a positive, as a negative?
What are they responding to? What's driving them away?
I mean VidMe already has a front page meta category for videos about VidMe
so
Research and development are already part of your business plan or at least they should be
and I'm not going to do that for free
Second the relationship between creators and platforms is inherently hostile
There's a huge incentive in the Internet age to approach everything as just pals
"We're all on the same side, we're in this together, get involved, help the site grow!"
The main problem there is that it's not actually true. We're not on the same side
Now, I as a content producer, and you as a platform developer have mutually beneficial goals
that are pointed in the same general direction
but our incentive sets on the granular level are quite different and diverge as the site's popularity grows
As the site gets more and more traffic your incentive as a platform
shifts from managing individuals to managing the product as a whole
and pivots hard towards managing relationships with advertisers instead of content creators
Of particular importance is that as these interests diverge
the individual creators lose bargaining power
RAY KROC: Mack, I'm the president and CEO
of a major corporation with land holdings in 17 States.
You're on a burger stand on the desert
I'm national. You're fucking local
To call back to a previous point
This is why I'm deeply suspicious of the "just pals, help the site grow" mentality.
We're just pals
until we're not
Any platform that doesn't codify their relationship with content creators, that
positions the relationship as "just pals" and "all on the same team" without any structural commitment
to that relationship is ultimately lying
It's easy to say that we're all just pals now
while the platform is new, while its hungry for content to drive traffic, while it's especially hungry for evangelists
that will do a lot of free marketing, purely by virtue of using the platform
Keeping in mind that a great many super successful YouTubers effectively
don't have a website or online presence outside of the one that exists on other platforms
Their YouTube Channel is functionally their website
Failing to codify this relationship ensure that the site will inevitably go through the change in incentives which will in turn lead
to the decision making that overwhelmingly favors advertisers at the direct expense of content creators
Any platform that isn't actively courting already successful content creators
by offering features and services that those users are looking for is
mildly doomed
YouTube is very successful
Monolithic, even.
If you simply try to recreate YouTube
who are your users going to be?
Well, generally speaking, it's going to be a lot of users with small to tiny channels,
and it's going to be the people that were too toxic for YouTube
That second one is a far bigger deal than I think most people in the position of platform development really appreciate
If you compete with a monolith the first people to jump on board
will be the people who were tossed off the other ship
and most of them were tossed off for a reason
Now, this can go either way
There's a lot of creators out there who are disillusioned with YouTube's systems, with the culture on the site,
the notoriously awful commenters and the inter channel targeting and harassment
They haven't necessarily been kicked off
But many of them have been driven away
The key point is that you get the audience you build, and if you don't build it
odds are you're going to end up with the dregs
This is why Dailymotion is largely inhabited by automated corporate accounts and
clickbait pseudoscience peddling diet pills
If a concerted active effort isn't made to cultivate the types of users that you want to see
then before you know what's happened, toxic users will have become your core users
And then you're never going to get out of that hole
So when I go on VidMe and the front page has a substantial concentration
of homophobic punditry and drama channels, it doesn't make me eager to come back
It tells me that you don't know who you want,
you don't know what YouTubers want, and so you're going to end up with whoever you happen to get
The critical point here is that it shows you don't know what YouTubers actually want
Both of the platforms mentioned, Maven Video and VidMe, are focused on monetization
which, yes, is an important concern of content creators
But there's already a lot of existing viable paths for monetization
While it's perhaps the most emotionally pressing issue, it's not the problem that needs the most solving
When you elevate monetization solutions to the top of the pile
When that's the selling feature that makes you different from YouTube
It tells me that what you're selling is the image of profitability to a crowd that is otherwise
not profitable on YouTube
While there is a certain degree of commendability in the goal of trying to help creators at the lowest tiers
get more attention and see some financial reward for their work
I'm inherently cynical towards any platform that positions itself in that way
without substantial formalized infrastructure to back it up because, frankly, we've seen it before
And it's because of all your support that we're now announcing this big thing
that will bring us closer than ever before, by creating a new way for us to create content together
In early 2016, The Fine Brothers attempted to launch React World
a brand licensing platform on a similar sort of promise
Using their platform would be a great opportunity to get paid for making reaction videos
because you would get the exposure that comes from using the React World brand
But they had no control infrastructure to back it up, there was no quality control, and thus no guarantee of performance.
It was pure rent-seeking
Maker Studios in early 2017 went through a massive upset that was years in the making
They recruited tens of thousands of small channels with a promise of better ad rates, high quality brand deals
and the vague promise of exposure and promotion with no solid commitments
In reality they delivered on none of those
and simply skimmed ad revenue off the top of the 60,000 channels they had brought into their network
It finally came to a head when Pewdiepie's racist practical jokes
made it clear that no one was at the wheel,
that Maker wasn't in the business of content and talent development
and were in fact just more rent seekers, luring in creators with poorly backed promises of getting paid
And they stole money from a lot of people
So if you're a new video platform and your core selling point your big launch feature is a tip jar
Forgive me if I'm having some Deja vu but I'm pretty sure I've heard this song before
I want to stress that point, the launch feature aspect
We live in a world after YouTube
YouTube already exists, YouTube already has over a decade of development
misdevelopment, feature creep, and general design cruft
YouTube has a number of vestigial features that are good ideas
but either they don't work well or they're functionally abandoned
because they're just tacked on or poorly implemented
Any new platform try to compete doesn't really need to reinvent the wheel
They're not figuring this out for the first time they just need to figure out how to make certain features work,
how to improve them, how to fold them into the core structure of their service
It's the launch features of a platform that are going to tell you the most
about a platform's values both in design and business
What features did they consider to be core to the identity and structure of the platform?
Where are their priorities?
There's a lot of successful YouTubers who would gladly jump ship from YouTube to another platform
if that platform offered features that on YouTube are either lacking or just plain bad
See, what YouTubers actually want is a platform that will take security seriously
that will care about harassment, abuse,
malicious use of automated services, will care about filtering and moderation tools and collaboration tools
YouTube has a feature that lets you cluster videos together as a packaged show
But it sucks, and no one uses it and even if you are using it the user experience is bad and lame
Contrast this with how the now-defunct Blip TV structured itself around serial content
Blip was far from perfect, but the user experience for watching something as a show was pretty good
It created a sense of continuity that's largely absent, or at best a tertiary consideration on YouTube
Despite the fact that YouTube is now the underpinning platform for some full-size businesses
YouTube's structure is still awful at handling any sort of multi-user setup,
let alone properly transitioning from a personal channel to a professional one managed by a team
If your channel is attached to a personal Google account, including say, your email
the only way to give someone access to the back-end of the channel is to give them access to the entire account
Additionally, powers cannot be partitioned between team members
Anyone with access to the channel enjoys full access to upload, download, delete, rename, moderate everything
This creates significant security concerns as compromising any individual member of the team compromises everything
YouTube's Playlist system is functional but hardly elegant
and the overall structure of the site as a whole makes it troublesome for content creators
to effectively compartmentalize content without segmenting their viewership
A secondary channel for specific types of content is effectively starting from scratch and needs to be maintained as its own entity
Additionally there's no way for channel managers to effectively migrate content from one channel to another
without going through the process of reuploading from scratch, requiring that all secondary data
from names to descriptions to captions and subtitles and thumbnails be re-entered, manually
Oh, and you lose existing comments, views, votes, and so on in the move
These are just a few of these structural site design issues with YouTube
not even addressing the cultural problems with a lack of moderation
unclear and unevenly enforced community standards and easily exploited automated systems
There are a wealth of deficiencies with YouTube that could all be centered as a core selling point for a competitor
To bring this back around I mentioned this
but it's my belief that you already employ people to do research and development
and did some market research before you even started building your platform
To me that seems like just a sensible business decision
You need to know your competitors,
you need to know your users, and you need to know the market
If you don't have that, well...
it doesn't exactly fill me with confidence
If you do have that and this is the site that you chose to launch
These are the features that you considered vital, that you figured would capture the audience that you're looking for
Well, it doesn't exactly fill me with confidence
Put simply, if someone's roasting your site on Twitter
your co-founder shouldn't be imploring them on Twitter to submit feedback and make the site better
because you should already know
If you haven't done your research,
if you haven't worked systems for security, moderation, and collaboration into the core infrastructure of the site
if those features aren't foundational to your design, then it's already too late
It means that you haven't built a YouTube competitor
You've just built a YouTube clone, and you're dooming yourself to the same mistakes
A frankenstein product built of cobbled-together features that don't properly integrate
The charitable reading is that you're just unprepared which isn't a good look on its own, but the worse reading
is that you're grifters, rent seekers, looking to exploit the hopes and labor of content creators
and the internet is already full of those